So should I split out the ads, like for,
let's say I do three ads for concrete,
like one is driveway, one is cement, one is patio.
Should I do it all in one or split it into three?
So repeat that question again.
So you're saying split the budget into three?
Yeah, or make three separate ads.
Like do only one ad that concentrates on cement keywords,
do another ad that only concentrates on patio keywords?
You know what?
That's a really good question.
I don't wanna give you guys,
I would not wanna give you advice that,
and I said this at the beginning of the call,
this would be a question
I would much rather fix it paid ads answer.
What I would want you to do on this question,
and I don't know if you caught this,
but we're actually redoing again the training on the ads
and also the entire training.
But for this specific question,
I think this would be valuable for everybody.
If you would post that, just that simple question,
say, whatever, post that in the group,
and then if you want to go a step further
and make a quick little loom and send it to me
and fix it paid ads, I'll give you an in-depth answer,
but I don't wanna just shoot something off the hip.
So would you do that for me?
Yeah, I'll definitely do that.
The only reason I ask is because
when you have targeted keywords for that ad,
you get to that 100%, how good the ad is.
You get poor, good, and excellent.
If it's all related,
you get closer to the excellent faster, that's why.
My knee-jerk reaction is I would tell you
to do a separate ad for each,
because yes, that is the relevancy,
that's really gonna help,
and we've noticed that that's been a big thing
with the way that we're doing ads now.
However, I also don't want to,
if there's somebody out there that's listening to this
and they hear, oh, three ads,
I would rather you just get them up
than not get them up at all.
So if that's causing analysis paralysis, no,
but yes, 100% what you're saying,
I think that is gonna be the answer.
But I would love for you to post that.
Let's get everyone's feedback.
I'll get fix it paid ads in there.